Infamous clown Pennywise is Las Vegas's
new celebrity resident and in this
month's old Vegas segment you're invited
to his home but good luck trying to
escape it
Las Vegas has the it Factor
inspired by one of the scariest and most
iconic film franchises escaping this
clone is not so funny I'm not going in
I'm not going in we are in the all-new
Escape it this is one of the largest
Escape experiences in the world this
thing is unbelievable 16 rooms that you
have to actually escape and fight
Pennywise I can't wait for everyone to
check this thing out well you know what
that means just call us the missing team
of eight news now hello I'm Maria I'm
wait this was a team building activity
I'm Selena and I'm the executive
producer and we got this we'll be fine
I'm not worried at all just know I have
my running shoes on
I don't trust it it's calm right now
you're walking fresh boss
[Music]
it's too short
hello
not worried huh from the infamous sewer
tunnels Selena to the kneebles house
the Escape it rooms immerse you into the
franchise's first film with 27 different
puzzles to solve okay
we've got from floor to ceiling to walls
around you do you see the details
crazy I mean we studied everything from
the stained glass in the Clown funeral
room to the exact Shutters on the knee
bolt house I mean we went to an extreme
degree to make sure that we satisfied
fans you know throughout the world that
come to visit us giving the
quintessential it and Vegas experience
and I call this a speakeasy style escape
room There's No Escape it signage on the
front of the building you've got Dairy
Public Works the Capitol Theater and of
course the Jade of the Orient Restaurant
so when you come in here you don't even
know where you're at so I like to set
the mood right off the bat when the
customers come up they're like I'm in
the right space they're like oh Dairy oh
yep we must be in the right space and
then the experience itself is over an
hour we've had groups taking an hour and
20 minutes to get through so definitely
you know grab a bite before you come
down here you know bring a bottle of
water with you because you're in here a
while I mean this thing like I said
chapter one alone is approximately 11
000 square feet of space it takes up it
is huge and yes chapter two is on its
way we're actually currently actively
working on chapter two as we speak and
they're going to be totally two
different attractions so not only do we
have the attraction we've got a
full-blown retail with a full Midway
Arcade and a museum which we're actually
standing in right now behind me are the
actual three doors from the It movie
which is unbelievable Warner Brothers
was nice enough to the loan us the doors
the actual bikes from the film and so
many other great props for people to
come out and see and along with that
there's also one of the original
Pennywise costumes that Bill Skarsgard
wore ultimately making Escape it over 30
000 square feet of Terror
eventually we made it out and to make up
for the tasty tasty beautiful Fear
Escape it also gives you a reason to
cheer
how thoughtful you can escape it with
memories and souvenirs
do you want a balloon too
thank you
[Music]
the answer the answer is no I do not
want a balloon too yes there's no I like
within the first 30 seconds you go oh
I'm not going in there but I did you did
we made it out obviously we are here did
Selena our executive producer get into a
coffin that was Selena getting in that's
part of the escaping I can't tell you oh
my God you gotta go to figure out
yourself but Pennywise you know he's so
fancy he requires a reservation to
escape him so book that in advance at
escapeit.com and that Jason is just so
hospitable huh you made it look so scary
and so fun I love that I'm gonna watch
it again